I love my mom but she knows that I
complain about the dumbest [ __ ] growing
up and she always she always hates it
when I mention it on the podcast she's
like it wasn't that bad you make it
sound so bad that's it
we wouldn't I don't know if you were you
had the same thing we were not allowed
branded products like it's just like so
if it was like if there was toothpaste
you bet we're getting like Tesco's own
if it was if it was crisps it you no way
in hell you having Walkers yeah it's
Tesco's or Little's own yeah everything
was like the store brand version of
everything because my mom believes she
she might she just cannot fathom she's
like they're all the same and okay
listen there are some products I'm with
you on that right yeah some products are
the same branded but get the [ __ ] out of
here if you think that little crisps
taste as good as Walkers they just they
flat out just don't because I do this
one time I had these they're like they
were like snack snack bites or some
snack of these or something there was a
[ __ ] name the packaging looks god-awful
and they taste like ass I opened up this
bag and there was just a brick of like
ash it was like coagulated crisps that
had been burnt to death it just came out
of the bag and it was black and it just
got Ash of like crisp Ash all over my
desk now like wouldn't happen with
Walker's mom your mom is literally the
epitome of we have walkers at home
she's literally just a bet I can't make
it I like I was such a little [ __ ] kid I
was like that she's like they don't even
want to bang Chris yeah I want a bag of
Walkers yeah because the kids at school
always had the Branded snacks and they
were they were so fired yeah it was so
good of course yeah because like for me
I was like exactly I had like exactly
the same thing but with technology yeah
right it was it was like oh God you have
your oh yeah you don't need it
back when mobile phones started to like
introduce right everyone had the [ __ ]
Nokia 3310 that's right right and I was
just like damn I wanted to get it not to
get a phone but to play Snake yeah Mike
was like gold the coolest [ __ ] games
it was on forever yeah and I was just
like so disappointed when I caught my
first phone and it was like a like a an
unbra I can't even [ __ ] remember the
brand it was like one of the cheapest
[ __ ] phones you could buy in like
phones for you or some [ __ ] like yeah
and I was just I remember they had like
they had games on it right but they had
this like the it was it wasn't even
snake it was like a very very cheap
knockoff of snake yeah and it was it was
pure copier me playing this being like
guys I'm having fun this is kind of like
snakes it's Cobra it's Cobra guys
I I my mum was very much against getting
me any of us a mobile phone yeah and she
she didn't for a very long time and then
she eventually caved when pretty much
everyone else had them had one and my
mom was like well I said I don't want to
get bullied so fine but yeah but I'm not
buying because back then you had to top
up right as well you had to put like
yeah oh yeah yeah you didn't text
because taxi was expensive yeah and he
had 140 carat limit OG Twitter days used
to like fit everything in yeah if you
didn't you were [ __ ] so yeah I mean it
took a while but I got it and yeah all I
did was just send funny Bluetooth videos
to each other and we'd have like the
what was that one video that went down
like the meadow it was the [ __ ] car oh
scary scary videos
[Applause]
that and for some reason that was the
funnest [ __ ] ever
we're so [ __ ] dumb now they get to do
now kids probably gonna have everything
I hope if I was entertained by that dumb
[ __ ] I don't know I remember oh my God
you just unlocked the memory so I
remember like it was my second ever
phone I got and like you know it was the
Motorola Razor
[Applause]
button on the side and it like goes like
that Joey's parents wealthy no no no so
I'm so I'm the oldest you know sibling
right I have younger sibling right but
like you know how like it's very
traditional where it's like if you have
an older sibling right you usually get
their hand-me-downs for a lot of things
right I didn't have an older sibling to
get my handy dance from I got it from my
dad
so as I had this like shitty [ __ ]
phone I don't even remember the brand of
it my dad had the Motorola Razor and
then when my dad was like I'm gonna get
myself a [ __ ] Blackberry yeah you can
have this [ __ ] shoes kids get the
Blackberry back in the day where like
the coolest [ __ ] they were the coolest
[ __ ] I don't know why that was like the
hype but I remember I got the I got the
the Motorola Razer right and this was
around the time where you could start to
use like you know custom ringtones all
right this is like the [ __ ] back in the
day where it's like you could like you
know download ringtones or like you know
if you figured out a way to like kind of
like uh you know pirate ringtones right
if you put them onto your phone you were
like the cool kid at school yeah and I
remember I was like at home and I was
just like surfing around I'm like man
friends around me have this [ __ ] cool
[ __ ] custom ringtones it sounds so
cool I want one as well so I start
looking it up yeah and I and I remember
I found off site that was like you can
get get this the Super Mario Brothers
theme as a ringtone on your [ __ ]
Motorola reason I was like just ten
dollars this is it and so I fill in some
[ __ ]
and I have it on my phone I go to school
the next day and I'm like check this out
show them ringtone they're like yo yo
dick as [ __ ] a month passes my dad
storms into my room oh no no and he's
like son why do you have a 2 000 phone
bill no what oh
it turns out the thing that I clicked
was a pop-up ad
and uh they were taking money from my
[ __ ] parents account for like three
or four weeks and like I don't remember
the exact amount it was but it was like
it was four digits and my dad was so did
you have to pay it uh yeah no and he was
like where the [ __ ] did you find it I
canceled it and um
yeah and I never got the big and I had
the biggest beating of my life like I
was like
I think the bloodline would end there
yeah that was my kid I'd be like yeah
what yeah [ __ ] I remember like I don't
know how we got resolved because
obviously I was very young with it yeah
but like by the time I realized it I was
like oh the Super Mario Bros ringtone is
gone from my phone you paid two thousand
dollars for the Super Mario Brothers
ringtone it was like at least a thousand
dollars oh my God yeah so um yeah don't
don't do that is uh is the thing but you
were the cool kid in school
three weeks yeah I was the cool kid in
school that had the Super Mario Bros
ringtone man I I kids were like yo where
the [ __ ] did you get them I'm not
telling them
all right watch have you been scammed
yeah you have I was I was I was thinking
about the same thing while I was like
have I ever been I'm trying to recall if
I haven't been scared yeah I've never
been scammed luckily that was the only
time I got scammed thank God but uh yeah
that was uh scary ah God because I
remember the first time like I I was
also a kid right I didn't I didn't well
even the main target is kids yeah and
elderly people yeah pretty much yeah
yeah it's like I could not even perceive
like the the like the even notion of
being scammed and I remember we ah this
is oh my God this is like unlocking a
memory right now it's I I remember we
got like some spam mail and now I
realize it's spam mail but at that time
I had I got this mail in and I remember
it's from it was from Reader's Digest
right okay I don't know what that is it
but it was I remember it was a comp the
company was Reader's Digest and it was
it was uh a male that said you have uh
you have past the next stage of this
raffle that you've entered and I'm like
what we've entered a raffle yeah yeah
and we're past the next stage I'm like
what mother we are about to be rich and
it was just like we because like
yeah yeah yeah I could I didn't even
think that we didn't even enter a raffle
I have a question
no no no no no no yeah yeah so so I saw
like the prize money and I saw that we'd
enter the that we'd enter the next day
surprise money was like thousands of
thousands of calls or something like
that
um but there were this this raffle this
competition was like several stages
right and I remember the second stage I
only had like a few more participants
left and to get to the next stage you
had to buy one of their books
that was like 25 pounds or something
like that and I was just like mother
we've already had zero investment in
this raffle we have reached the next
stage may I procure your credit card for
just a moment while I buy this other
book mother you know what they're saying
you got to spend money to make money so
uh I'm sorry and so I think my mum like
I I don't know I think my mom just went
with it one because I just seemed happy
and two just as a learning experience
for me right so I buy this book this
[ __ ] book gets sent to my house and
of course I wish you got a book huh yeah
yeah I got a book about from Reader's
Digest about the [ __ ] architecture of
castles in Edinburgh so I'm sure right
and then so we get the book yeah then
we'll get a note with it saying
congratulations you've reached the next
stage of you've been successful in
reaching the next stage in the raffle uh
to reach the next stage you have to buy
two books and I'm like oh my god
mother we are far in now to say no okay
there are only a few participants left
and I think I think she let me go for
about two more stages
and I was just like Mom we're too deep
into this to like give up now mum please
how many books did you end up with like
[ __ ] five or seven yeah she got seven
books about lovely castles yeah
I let you and then she was like no I
just
gone you're a [ __ ] idiot okay do not
do this again do not fall for this again
okay and I was just like what do you
mean they were lying mom we're almost
there we're just close we're this close
to winning the grand prize and that was
my first scam that I ever fell for damn
um hey at least you got seven books yeah
I got seven books out of it though so
one of the main reasons you know people
the scams are so successful because
people don't talk about it when they
have been scammed there's a lot of Shame
around it yeah people are too ashamed to
admit they've been scared oh yeah yeah
which makes sense right because if
you've been scammed out of a significant
amount of money where it affects your
life then yeah you know you would feel
stupid you know that's valid but you
know you still should talk about it
because the main reason they keep
getting away with it because people
don't know about it yeah dude I okay
they've been countless occasions where
between the ages of like 16 to even like
now I've like there have been some
emails that are so goddamn convincing
and good yeah and came at like because
obviously they send these emails out in
Mass yeah right yeah and obviously every
now and then they'll send you an email
at the exact right time when it you just
you you're like huh you know like for
example like an Amazon refund scam or
something yeah maybe you just hit the
refund button and then a mass scam was
set out just by happenstance right yeah
yeah and then you're like huh I guess I
have to claim the money now yeah that's
weird so you kind of fall for it right
but then obviously the more you look
into it yeah I've nearly fallen for
scams like that a few times I remember
there's one where it was like sent to do
with um uh I I just submitted my tax
refund pretty easy to figure out right
yeah figure out April or whatever yeah
in the UK and I look really convincing
the website was really legit everything
looked good I typed in most of my
information it hadn't hit send or
anything and I thought hold on a second
let me go back and have a look more at
this email in depth and saw that you
know the easiest way to tell is
sometimes the sender yeah has a [ __ ]
email yeah but even then like there was
that one YouTube scam that went around
for do you remember the Scandal yeah I
remember the scam where it was like it
was from like you Google uh something at
google.com yeah yeah yeah and if
somebody's from google.com uh that's
normally like the actual Google services
yeah and for some reason YouTube allowed
a Google and YouTuber allowed this to
happen where they were like your AdSense
is going to be terminated and that's
obviously like wow this is that's [ __ ]
up this is this is something that is
very uh pressing and it would the way
that they had worded it was something
something along the lines where it
sounded believable because I fell into
that category of whatever they were
saying what the [ __ ] I nearly fell for
that one too I was like on the Google
messenger chat talking to this [ __ ]
weirdo transcam me yeah nearly fell for
it but didn't damn it's hard man no
matter how screwed on your head is man
you can they always find it they're just
getting more and more they're right the
right scam at the right time can you
could fall for it like you might think
you're like Ironclad and you'll never
fall for anything but yeah just the
right timing I'm like oh you'll be cool
well like YouTube has a [ __ ] massive
problem right now with I don't know if
you guys the bots on like every reply
for every [ __ ] comment it's like it's
always the first reply and it's always
you you know
yeah it's always you but usually it's
like slightly misspelled
it's lazy man
[ __ ] profile pictures like oh yeah
that's probably him yeah